look we're live where the hot new word
that everyone is saying but what does it
mean roll the intro leave your entries
in us already closed episode why what a
week it has been oh look what is this
YouTube removes Logan Paul as preferred
and partner and cancel his YouTube read
projects I mean Logan welcome to the fam
come here someone needs a hug I know how
it feels
don't worry just make sure your videos
are ten minutes long and you add an
extra mid Rowling you should be fine
that you shouldn't notice any difference
don't worry about it it's it's gonna be
great for you Logan I know you were
trying to become like a billionaire or
something like that
I'm sure dreams come true for those who
wait now in the meantime we're gonna
review the memes that you have posted on
that PewDiePie submission subreddit it
is the greatest subreddit on all of
Reddit okay you don't need to go
anywhere else but to this place huh we
got memes about my chair I can't do this
I mean because my chair is $3.99 check
out my chair now now that we have that
out of the way let's review the meats Oh
will you look at that does this chair
need its own channel or something with
what's happen you want to spend 399
already nice game oh look at that
March 2018 the year of the chair
god dammit when people ask how you make
millions and billions of dollars well
yes
seeing how much I made him my last March
sale I understand why Logan keep pushing
for his merch man
damn I could retire guys there is hope
buy my chair so I can retire I have
spaghetti no no et books are so useful
you can read thousands of book with just
one small device it's so much better
than normal bits yeah that's all cool
and stuff but game you need it no they
can't Kindle can't so far we have three
out of four chair memes let's move on a
video
[Music]
so much better
laughs midday chime for some time
[Music]
all right no no no buzz there god damn
it I'm gonna leave a link to this one in
the description check it out YouTube you
need to leave these these people in
church for your rewind you didn't even
have to shoot anything you don't even
need a budget and it's already a hundred
times better my god incredible I'm the
greatest bird the perfect hunter and the
sign of a nation
why is that funny it's not only 3.99 and
that bald eagles nick will just go
skillet oh yeah
Brad told me about this they basically
youtuber at red release like another
episode of their show called do you want
to see a dead body at the same time as
everything was happening they would look
they try they try to push that down a
bit but no they're like a Peter Pan and
then and you want to see a dead body
though give me money please I need order
I need to order a prostitute friend what
that man
money doesn't hang on trees oh [ __ ] a
lot of your Logan Paul Logan Paul going
beyond the deep fish fish
philosophical I just said I already lost
the point I don't know why I even try to
speak anymore
someone sent help for $3.99 you can sing
[Music]
399 hey wanna go out on a date with me
sorry I have a boyfriend I'm a nice guy
my boyfriend is a nice guy too but
gainey duty what do i do if i'm a lemon
you can still respect women if you're a
wham and don't make me laugh stupid
women don't know how to respect me you
need to photoshop PewDiePie's face on
him yes I can look at this edit that
Brad did or Simon's but can you do
[Music]
somebody touched my spaghetti
somebody's in this house good me
unexpected so we were bored in math
class today and someone someone's
ringtone went off as the mean in the new
pd pi video sweet smile sadistic suicide
and some girl yelled out stop being a
jerk to Logan and of course ringtone boy
said can he do this and he looked back
did that actually happen hmm
and then the whole class clapped and the
teacher gave him $100 because he was a
genius don't forget that Einstein showed
up to congratulate the young genius and
the Jung young genius named Albert he
started with very nice though the
teacher gave him 399 so he thanks
goodness
Peabody has changed so much over the
years I'm so proud of him we're going to
show you a series of videos with the
challenges you can't smile or laugh
while watching why not that's the whole
point it's a challenge
[Music]
so sad sometimes sometimes I wake up at
night and I think to myself Jesus Christ
I've become raywilliamjohnson that girl
is so cute I wonder what she's listening
to you oh yeah did you see looking man
man sang it so good
wait someone matched us together let's
check it out
[Laughter]
[Music]
Domon hand
if Swedish is so incredible like I
didn't know who was a Swedish man
[Applause]
please some caption him
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh Johnny you're a legend thank you very
much for making this the YouTube app
seems to be broken for me can you check
it out hi Anna rude let us know what
it's happening and we'll do our best
scare PewDiePie season 2 is it out yet
and you said it was gonna come out in
March that's right
scare PewDiePie season 2 in March it's
gonna happen or else YouTube will face
my anger do you want me angry YouTube oh
my god is there another bait can you
guys stop well done well then keep
baiting YouTube actually that's funny
cutting the video if PewDiePie is
answering the door reaching the ten
minute I'll Brad meme how about that
look at that Brad gets to be included
too bad no one cares about side 4 only
399 you can become a true Swiss tchen as
well the vast majority of you cannot
afford me you have a voice now can you
shut up about me for once don't listen
to the channel listen don't listen to
the chick okay team
I need another three minutes for the
video what should I do
check your door advertise your chair
watch more means yeah maybe if you posed
if some actually decent means I could
watch more memes up vote for pills to
play as a song and his guitar okay
alright leave your answers in the
comments below I'll keep my favorites in
the next episode up Wow it's not tuning
it's missing a string and I can't be
bothered right now okay leave your means
in the Lawai subreddit you could get
immortalized people who look at this
show in the future and say this is where
it all started this is where it all went
downhill do you want to be part of
history or not I'm giving you this
opportunity to post our means my dudes
check out the link in the description
submit your mean I know you're sitting
on that haha don't miss out on it and
that's it for me for now leave a like if
you are watching thank you guys for
submitting all the memes I love it this
has become my favorite show and my my
weekly favorite thing literally
I don't even have to prepare anything I
just didn't start the day